oh boy last night was so fun hanging out
with Ethan the Gila they're really cool
people I really like those guys I'm just
really tired
jeesus what happened oh yeah
vodka good ol vodka all right so I'm
walking Marci over to her friend cuz
she's gonna play with her friend today I
have nothing to do until scare PewDiePie
starts at 3:00 we're halfway through the
show scary I don't know it's so fun but
at the same time it's very intense
just to keep out the daily vlogs I'm
just like yeah it's insane how much work
you do I'm tired yeah how did daily
vloggers do it all the time
seriously they must have like schedules
or something cuz I'm just like I don't I
don't I don't know what to do
Hey well I'm hoping I can get Brad a
strike now no that's why you're walking
yeah Wow
yeah so do I we both drank last night
damn it goddamn it I walk all this way
to give you a stupid strike and you're
wearing your stupid shirt I'm losing how
you feeling
really bad me too I'm really bad yeah
[Music]
that didn't help at all
[ __ ] we're going to scare PewDiePie
I'm so [ __ ] tired what happened man I
slept so long - I woke up at 11:00
episode six
what do you think will happen I'm so
ready for ten hours doesn't seem like it
so ready for the long sheet in late
night shape but you will enjoy it do you
think so I know it's gonna be a good one
that's good
[Music]
so
stairs right here on the way let down a
little bit into the bathroom are you in
Michael
nothing sitting on the floor want a
banana
no what time is it it's 5:00 we're
supposed to start soon they're being
very secret about this one so I don't
know what's going on I feel weird got to
keep all the blindfolds on I need to
wake the [ __ ] up I'm so tired
Michael do you want this banana up your
ass cuz I'm good
yeah good come right that's right all
right well we should be starting soon
which way you good
follow me okay before we start put this
all your all your stuff down first and
make it alright if you don't want to go
in the rubble [ __ ]
community men who drink coffee
go
all right
wait how do I like do I look dead dead
and that's I feel insane what do you
think will happen today different true
well they just told me prison and the
guess is loser
so you told you and the game is
uncharted who told you this
sure oh ok but still are you excited
yeah I'm excited when I heard it was
Uncharted yeah alright which game do you
think this is can you guess you're not
supposed to I guess um I'm so tired this
episode all these people are working on
this and I'm just like I want to sleep
it should be really fun though I'm
excited still but I need awake
we done three so far oh come on man
come just watch just watch
wow what a blooper did this is what
happened what he said yes right everyone
water bottle really shot really bad
nobody did you would be the most amazing
trick on the Internet I call this one
from the tree
kilala shot human no it lose I'm falling
I'm falling how have my legs oh yeah
that's just a little bit more Oh another
one
it was one yeah jimang out let's see how
strong you really are
come on boy come on boy it's time it
stopped this thing that we've done is so
badass on a cop car come you think
you're stronger right he's messed up you
strong mr. spaghetti all right sweetie
so much you'd call it count it down
three two one go what wait wait you're
sweet as in power I'm spitting all over
you from our cue if anyone thinks that I
was actually like a bottle strength he
was the opposite I get it stops now I
get it
you're subs are mine
hola espanol espadrille pie hey
subscribe subscribe subscribe subscribe
a tempo deep ahh hey drop ah thanks for
letting me win man I appreciate that
when I heard Martin that was my you're
like I have to she's gonna see this hold
the try ha ha edge go
Oh [ __ ] up ha ha ha that is what
happens when you plate early from the
beginning
look at him Z's boy kick him hey boy he
go current attackin that's funny
do it kick him in the butt ah what's
wrong with you should
yeah that's beautiful definitely not
that's your that's your throne now you
beat me you beat you get to sit on the
throne you know what when you know from
the beginning that is a bad idea this is
it it's actually Oh what damn it
you throw bearish man I hope you're
happy for he's like speaking in the
Christmas tree do you think do you think
they left one unlocked surely one must
be fitted compare you dare me to go in
get in
I mean what if the alarm goes up didn't
tell I'm we go out where the door is
open
holy [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] cold man
yeah wait here gender it's closed
really I was a co-pilot one I paid the
button to open it for right
Oh oh no I locked it boy I locked it I
am finally I got that Michael [ __ ]
right where I want him
can you like Lockheed manacle can you
like lock him in and then just we leave
him in there one Michael see you Michael
call nine one why good luck with the
strike thing in one one finally finally
that was good dude my heart was pumping
I was like I thought that our alarm
would go well now we just filmed a
felony grinding great dude nine hours
later know how thankful are you oh you
got I got it open
oh how do you do it because my tie left
it open Oh loser what the hell would we
have done
Shane trouble like how the hell would we
do that Jesus Christ Michael I'm sorry
hahaha I'm [ __ ] glad you can't that
oh my god I'm here to serve
part of me was like really happy out of
power to me like Who am I blaming this
on oh I was [ __ ] freaking out welcome
to America son that's not Michael
that's what you get on a holiday
Michael I saw your face when you you
know when he tried to open the door yeah
yeah why do they leave the cop cars on
the lawn because no one's so stupid to
go inside a cop car there it is that was
almost your home that's it good I can't
believe that happen oh yeah I don't know
I I try to reach all you could no you
can't do that yeah that way they're
probably they're designed so you can't
yeah yeah [ __ ] me man
dude I got adrenaline I really freak me
out
my heart sank man I was like as soon as
you went for that lock and you've moved
it I thought oh [ __ ] it's up who do you
who do you call there's no way out
there's no one here
Oh what is this you're 13 days late you
got 13 strikes i got dicks everywhere
can we switch shirts please okay so this
whole vlog I was literally tired all day
because I took Advil PM which it says
here there for nighttime sleep aid and I
took four of them so first I took them
because I was hungover because I thought
it would headache pills and I slept for
so long I never slept this long before
and I was like I don't understand why
and then I took two more I guess I was
having another headache and I was just
sleepy all day as he saw and I gave
something bread to and Brad was like I
can't make it through this she said I'm
too tired and I'm like what I just
this explains it I was like why am I so
tired everything yeah why am I so tired
I don't get it Advil PM I thought they
were just headache pills I didn't know
there was nighttime sleep aid Jesus I
was so tired the whole day I've been
saying to people all day that he felt
like you spiked me yeah you kept
complaining I'm like I don't understand
I am really tired like if they [ __ ] me
up and I was like it feels like someone
has like drugged me haha and it turns
out I've been drugged
well another day of barnable we're going
to Vegas tomorrow I forgot to tell you
so you should be really fine leave it
like you enjoyed and I'll see you and
then expert about
preface
[Music]